CLIFF REDEKER: So today, we're
extremely thrilled to bring
Brian Klapper here to Google.
He is the founding partner
of the Klapper Institute.
He's the author of the book
that we're listening in on
today, "The Q-Loop: The Art
and Science of Lasting
Corporate Change".
And over lunch I had a really
great conversation with him,
and one of the things that we
picked up upon is that change
is something that all
organizations face as they
increase in years and
increase in size.
And really, adaptation to change
is important, but what
is even more important is just
providing a framework for
these ideas to be expressed
instead of repressed.
And so, as companies grow, it's
very critical that they
stay nimble, and so "The Q-Loop"
outlines ways that
companies in all industries can
adapt to that strategy.
So we will have some time for
some Q&A in the end, but in
the meantime, please join me in
welcoming Brian to Google.
So thank you very much.
BRIAN KLAPPER: Thank you.
It's an honor to be here.
I thought I'd start with a
personal story to kind let you
know how I got into this
business of change, something
that Cliff and I were talking
about over lunch.
And for me, it started--
I was a partner in one of the
big strategy firms for many
years, and we were given the
honor of working for a major
money center bank, directly
for the CEO.
And we spent a year working for
this guy, and he asked us,
he said, I'll give you a blank
check, but what I want you to
do is develop a strategy for
me that'll help me reinvent
banking for the 21st century.
As a strategy guy, it just
doesn't get better than that.
That's as good as it gets.
It's a white sheet of paper,
it's a blank check.
It was fabulous.
Spent a year working
for the bank.
We had teams and teams of
analysts producing hundreds
and hundreds and hundreds of
models on economic and
financial analysis, and
by the end, we finally
presented to him.
Picture a very large conference
room, polished
mahogany, it was magnificent.
The partners were in the room,
presented to the CEO, and at
the end of the presentation,
he smiled and he said, I'd
like to congratulate you folks
on maybe the most brilliant,
insightful piece of strategy
I've ever seen.
I said, oh, thank you,
that's great.
He takes the deck, throws it
against the conference room
wall, the binder clip opens up,
all of the pages scatter
around, and he tells us, I don't
think it's worth the
paper it's printed on,
nevertheless the tens of
millions of dollars I spent
with your firm.
So we said, OK, A, can you go
back to the point of how
brilliant we were, because that
was a much more enjoyable
conversation.
But I guess, B, why not?
And he said, you know what?
I think I understand 85% of
what's in here, and I think
I'm a pretty clever guy.
I have 160,000 people
that work for me.
What am I supposed
to do with this?
What do I tell them to
do with this work?
And so one of my partners
volunteered and said, well, if
you look at chapter 47 of the
deck, you'll see that there
are Gantt charts, and pert
charts, and roles,
responsibilities, guidepost
jobs, accountability.
We have all of that.
He said, that's not what
I'm talking about.
What do I do with this?
How do I get 160,000 people
to basically sing
off the same hymnal?
I don't get it.
So I flew back home,
pretty dejected.
Inconsolable, actually, for
the entire weekend.
And then my wife said to
me, you know what?
I think he probably gave you
the kindest gift that any
client has ever given you.
I said, what are you
talking about?
This was a disaster.
I said, OK, what gift?
He was honest.
I wonder how many of your other
clients felt the same
way that he did.
You did some highfalutin
strategy work, but at the end
of the day, they couldn't
implement.
I said, you don't know what
you're talking about.
My clients love me, repeat
business, long term-- she
goes, OK, I'm sure
you're right, OK.
But I was thinking about it, and
I actually decided to then
go ahead and audit my former
clients to find out what
percent actually got that full
value of the work that we had
created for them.
And lo and behold,
it was like 16%.
So I quit two days later.
I said, I can't do
this anymore.
So I decided I wanted to get out
of the ideas business, and
actually get in the trenches
with clients and help clients
really implement change.
Because that's something that,
quite frankly, companies large
and small, young and old, always
have a difficult time
doing, is really driving
change through their
organization.
And there are many, many
reasons for that.
And that's what I wanted to
spend most of our time talking
about today, are what are some
of the reasons why change is
so difficult for different
companies?
And why there's so much talk and
so many great ideas, but
organizations don't always
receive the full benefit of
all those ideas.
So, as an example, suppose you
know of two artists, one of
whom has brilliant ideas and
always takes those ideas and
puts them down on paper and
translates them into
beautiful, beautiful
pieces of work.
The other artist has equally
brilliant ideas, but they
never make it down
to the canvas.
I think we could all agree that
the first artist is, in
fact, a brilliant artist.
But what of the second?
I guess I would argue the second
artist isn't really an
artist at all.
He's a talker, and there's a
very big difference between
being a talker and
being an artist.
And what I've seen when I visit
so many companies is
companies love to
reward the idea.
And they mistake brilliant ideas
for constructive action,
and that becomes a problem.
And people often get promoted
not on their ability to
actually drive change through
an organization, but more on
their ability to
generate ideas.
And so why is that, and
what's the difference?
Well, ideation is fun, right?
Especially at a company
like this.
Who doesn't love kicking
around ideas?
It's a great time, it's fun.
The challenge, though, is
implementation is hard.
It involves changing people.
It Involves influence.
It involves changing
org structures.
It's very different having an
idea and getting an idea fully
implemented.
And one of the reasons,
quite frankly,
is the fear of failure.
There's not a lot of failure
at the ideation level.
Failure comes at the lack
of implementation level.
I recently heard of this really
interesting story.
Well, I liked it anyway.
And it was of a six-year-old
girl.
And the six-year-old girl never
really paid a lot of
attention in her core subjects,
but she was sitting
in the back of the room,
diligently focused on some
drawing that she was making.
So much so that the teacher
said, I really want to
investigate what this girl's
doing, because I've never seen
her focus quite this
way before.
So she goes back, and she talks
to this little girl, and
she says, excuse me, what
are you working on?
And the little girl looks up
in disgust and says, I'm
drawing a picture of God, and
goes back down to her work.
To which the teacher replies,
but we don't know what God
looks like.
And the little girl looks up
and says, you will in a
minute, and goes back
down to work.
On a more personal note, my wife
and I were going through
our DVD collection, and we
decided for Mother's Day this
past year, we wanted to give our
mothers a compilation DVD
of our kids growing up
through the years.
And we came across one of my
youngest daughter, Danielle,
she's now 13, she was
in kindergarten.
And the teacher asks the entire
kindergarten class, who
knows how to make a Thanksgiving
dinner?
Out of nowhere, my daughter's
hand shoots up, and I look
around, she's the only one
in the class with her
hand up in the air.
Not always right, but always
certain, my Danielle.
And so she raises her hand,
teacher calls on her, and
without prompting she stands up,
because she needed to be
an orator for this answer.
And she stands up, and
she says, I know how
my parents do it.
First, they get a bunch of
turkeys, then they get up a
bunch of pilgrims.
They stuff both the turkeys and
pilgrims with stuffing so
they're fat, and then our
family eats them all.
Not quite the way things work in
our family in Connecticut,
but nonetheless.
So, what do the two stories
have in common?
Between the little girl drawing
the picture of God,
and my daughter Danielle
convinced that we're cannibals?
They don't feel failure.
Kids never feel failure.
They only see the upside.
They never consider the
downside, and that's probably
something, as we get older, we
recognize that decisions and
ideas have consequences.
But not to the kids.
What I see so often in so many
companies is so many companies
try and stigmatize failure.
I'm working with a client now
who says, we've always been a
company that likes to
take three shots
and score three goals.
I want to be a company that
takes seven shots takes, 10
shots, and scores seven times.
And that's a great ambition,
unless you're one of those
three people that
shot and missed.
So the question is, how can
you-- because if you're not
willing to fail, you'll never
come up with something new.
You'll never come up with
something innovative.
So how do you build an
organization, how do you build
a process, that allows
for failure--
I would argue that even
encourages failure, pursues
failure in a way that promotes
creativity, promotes ideation,
and, ultimately, promotes
implementation?
Now, failure is part
of change.
And when you do the research,
you'll realize that over 70%
of all company-wide change
efforts fail to deliver their
intended results.
And that's something small--
like we want to improve our
time to market for
new products--
or something large--
we want to transform our
entire organization.
70% of all efforts fails.
And when I talk to C-suite
executives, what they tell me
is, we have fabulous people.
Our corporate culture
is terrific.
Our technology is fine, if
not better than fine.
Yet why is it so hard
for me to get
anything done around here?
I've got 10,000, 20,000, 50,000
people, all presumably
going in different directions.
I can't get them galvanized
around some of the major
issues that I'm looking for
in my organization.
Why is that?
And when you dissect it, the
roadmap for change is actually
relatively straightforward.
You create a vision, a strategy,
communication plan,
and then ignite people
to execute.
Well, the vision--
executives don't get promoted to
executive positions without
being visionary.
So most executives have
that box checked.
Strategy-- there's been tons
written about strategy, firms
built around strategy.
Also something not terribly
difficult,
once you have a vision.
Communication plans, there are
dozens from which to choose.
You can go on the internet and
find a million of them.
Again, not terribly
challenging.
The question is the last one.
And this is where they
all breakdown.
85% of the 70% break down in
the inability to ignite an
organization around a
theme around change.
And that's the challenging
part.
Yet, if you don't change, and
even as a company, if you are
not able to change and make
change an ongoing part of your
core capability, you're going
to have an issue.
Interesting statistic--
back in 1917, only one of the
Forbes greatest companies
performed better
than average--
average, in this case,
being the S&P 500.
And 85 of those 100 are dead.
They are no longer
in business.
I find that both frightening
and sobering.
Especially because, what does
it take to become one of the
Forbes top 100 companies?
You folks would know.
Great products, great people,
great ideas, great market
position, in some cases,
great location.
So you've got everything going
for you, yet 85% are no longer
in business.
As Michael Collins has said,
it's not because of what the
world does to these companies.
It's what the companies
do to themselves that
causes them to fail.
When you peel back the numbers,
some interesting
themes emerge.
Three primary ones
as to why these
companies are out of business.
Number one, adherence to a
business model that's no
longer relevant.
So, the marketplace changed, the
business model didn't, and
the company went out.
Blockbuster.
Secondly, the company took its
eye off the customer ball.
So how do you make
money, right?
You meet the needs--
both the implicit and
explicit needs--
of customers, both what they
want now, and even what they
don't know what they want it.
And the extent you can
anticipate what customers
want, that will be a successful
business model.
Companies took their eye off
that particular ball.
Consumer tastes change,
companies
didn't, they went out.
In that same bucket, it's
companies that tend to design
products more for themselves
than for customers fall risk
to that particular model.
Third, and last, is companies
lost out to more nimble
competitors.
What was once the new, new thing
stopped becoming the new
thing, and, as a result, they
had a talent drain.
They had a brain drain.
And some of their most creative
people got frustrated
working in what was once
a very entrepreneurial
organization, and they left to
either start their own firms
or to work in companies that
represented the ideal which
was the company that they
thought they joined.
So those are the three primary
reasons why you see
organizations change.
Gary Hamel, in his book "Leading
the Revolution", had
a great quote.
This is going back probably 15
years, even before Amazon
became relevant, and it was
commenting on Walmart.
And he said, how many people
think the retailing revolution
will start with Walmart?
Who amongst us wants to spend
our time walking around the
soulless canyons of
Walmart looking to
save $10 on a hammer?
And he hit it right, because if
you think about where did
we buy hammers when
we were kids?
Probably the local
hardware store.
And then where?
The big box retailer.
And then Kmart, and then
Walmart, and then Amazon.
Where's it going to go?
Who knows.
3D printers, maybe, who knows
where it's going to go?
But it's not going to
stop with Walmart.
Let me ask you a question.
Does anybody know, back in the
1960s, early '70s, what the
largest restaurant chain in
the United States was?
Not McDonald's, young man.
Howard Johnson's.
Anyone ever hear of them?
Red roof, orange sherbet,
popularized in Mad Men?
Howard Johnson had over 1,000
restaurants around the United
States on the most popular
highways, they had the best
location of any of them.
They were the number two food
producer after the US Army,
and their market share was
larger than McDonald's, Burger
King, and KFC combined.
And what was their
business model?
Bring your kids in, have a nice,
comfortable meal, relax,
take your time, and we'll
serve you good food at a
reasonably good price,
in a very
relaxing, enjoyable setting.
Now, imagine that you've got a
larger share than McDonald's,
Burger King, and KFC combined.
You've got the best location,
you've got fabulous products,
and your customers love you.
So imagine you're up at the
board of directors.
You're sitting at a board of
directors meeting for Howard
Johnson's, and an analyst comes
in who's responsible for
competitive research and says,
folks, I think I've seen the
future, and this is our
biggest competitor.
It should strike fear
in your hearts.
That's our competitor.
What's your reaction?
You've got to be kidding me.
The clown?
I'm going to get taken
out by the clown?
And you obviously know
how the story went.
So what happened?
Why did the clown win?
Women were getting into
the workforce,
time became a commodity.
People didn't have the time,
nor the patience, nor the
interest to spend with their
families eating long family
comfort meals.
They wanted quick, they wanted
cheap, they want to
get in and get out.
And there was no place better
positioned than Howard
Johnson's to take advantage
of that.
Yet the clown won.
So, I wrote this book, "The
Q-Loop", and the Q-loop was
designed to really offer a
process of ideation through
implementation.
And people say to me, why a Q?
What's with that?
And it's the flow of ideas, or
what should be the flow of
ideas but isn't always.
So at the top of the Q--
I like to think of the top
of the Q as the top of an
organization.
The senior management.
There's nobody more visionary,
there's no one that should be
looking out over the
horizon, more
than your senior managers.
And they do, for
the most part.
Ideally, in the Q-loop, though,
they would then start
organizations on what I
call an idea quest.
Come up with a focus mission,
and then bring that idea
quest, that vision down to the
bottom of the organization.
Down to your front line people,
your first and second
level supervisors.
That's where that could be
wellspring of ideas for the
organization, and is
almost never used.
Then back up to the top of the
organization for resourcing
and staffing, and then back
down one more time for
piloting and then out the
Q for implementation and
firm-wide rollout.
One of the questions I ask when
I'm in these kinds of
meetings is, I talk about a
concept that I'm quite fond
of, and it's called
organizational
IQ, collective IQ.
And the notion there is, let's
say you've got an organization
of 10,000 people with an
average IQ of 120.
That's 1.2 million IQ points
available to the organization.
And when I asked senior
executives what percent of
that 1.2 million IQ points do
you take advantage of in your
decision making, your ideation,
your input into
strategic planning, for the most
important decisions you
companies makes,
what do I get?
1 to 5%.
Ideas, visions come from the top
of the organization, and
they stay in that very top of
the Q, and they never make it
down to the lower ends
of the organization.
And why does it matter?
Well, because the folks that
are on your front lines are
the ones closest to
your customers.
They're the ones that witness
millions and millions and
millions of customer
interactions, and do you know
what they do with them?
Typically, absolutely nothing.
They keep them to themselves.
They are busy typically
protecting an organization
from the customers.
Nobody wants to see how the
souffle is made, and that's
what your front line
workers do.
I call them heroes, because they
are the ones that prevent
your customer from really
peering inside to how things
really work in most
organizations.
And it's a vast treasure trove
of information that is almost
never taken advantage of, and
I think that's a big shame.
In addition, you're asking
these people to
implement your ideas.
How many people love
to implement
someone else's ideas?
Show of hands.
Few people like to implement
other people's ideas.
But people fall over themselves
to implement the
ideas that they had a
hand in creating.
Why wouldn't they?
And especially if your front
line, first level supervisors,
these are the people where
the pragmatism exists.
They're not in the ivory tower
up on the top floor of an
office building, these are the
people in the trenches.
They're going to war every day
on behalf of the company.
So there's huge pragmatism that
exists on the front line,
and all of the ideas that would
come from these people
typically are very pragmatic in
nature and easy to implement.
So, if you follow the Q-Loop
concept, it's vision up front,
ideas come from the front line,
up to the front again
for resourcing, for span of
control, for prioritization,
back down for testing, and then
out for implementation.
And yes, testing is extremely
important.
Ask JCPenney what happens when
you implement great ideas that
aren't previously tested.
So, rapid cycle innovation is a
fabulous tool, not just for
IT products, but for processes,
for org structures,
for incentive structures.
It works brilliantly.
Before you can implement
something like Q-Loop, though,
it's helpful to understand how
you currently solve problems
in your current organization,
or how you realize
opportunities.
So, I built this matrix.
On the x-axis is understanding
the degree to which you
believe your solution will
contribute to solving an
issue, or realizing
an opportunity.
On the y-axis is to what extent
you as an organization
deeply understand why that
issue has occurred.
Why the problem has occurred, or
why that opportunity might
present itself.
70% of all organizations
are in this first box.
We don't understand why the
problem occurred in the first
place, and we really have no
idea how our solution is going
to solve the problem.
And we call that firefighting.
And that's just gathering a
bunch of people a room,
throwing them against a task,
and eventually, if they are
the right people, you're going
to find that they're going to
come up with a solution.
Now, will they understand
the causality?
Probably not.
Will the solution stick
and be robust?
Doubtful.
But it will have them solve
the problem in relatively
short order.
And some organizations
thrive on it.
They love the chaos.
It's just not sustainable and
not good business practice.
It's certainly not efficient.
If we go along the x-axis--
so I really understand how my
solution will solve the
problem, but I don't have the
faintest idea of what the
problem occurred, nor what
the great idea could be.
We call that tribal wisdom.
So what is that?
That means there's a great
opportunity for us here, we
want to enter a new market,
we call George.
George is the new
market expert.
George comes riding in on this
big white horse, dismounts,
and says, OK, folks, minions,
tell me the problem.
I, George, will solve it for
you with the aid of my big
white horse.
And George solves the problem.
Why?
Because he's George, and he's
got a big white horse.
And that's a fine way to solve
problems provided George never
goes on maternity leave,
provided George never leaves
the company, provided the
problem is always within
George's wheel house.
So it's a very risky way to
solve problems when you rely
solely on experts.
Young, emerging companies
typically solve
problems this way.
Tons of pockets of expertise,
bring in George and the horse,
they solve the problems, George
goes back, organization
feels, well, that's gone.
Until the next problem.
But by not codifying this, by
not building part of your
institutional knowledge, you're
always relying on George.
The problem with implementing
a more robust approach to
ideation through change is
you're going to have
resistance, as we
talked about.
Who do you think the biggest
resistor will be?
George.
Why?
Because the day that all boats
rise is the day you take away
George's horse.
And who is George without
his horse?
He's a little guy that
just solves problems.
So he's going to resist
tooth and nail.
So how do you solve that?
You include George in ideation,
because if you
don't, he's going to resist.
And we don't want him to leave,
because he has talents
that none of us have.
If we go, we say on our current
level on the x, we go
up the y-axis to where you have
no idea how our solution
is going to solve the problem.
But we love generating
potential ideas.
We do, however, have a pretty
good insight as to what the
marketplace wants, or why the
problem is occurring.
We call this the conference
room solution--
I call this conference
room solution.
It's my least favorite
of the four boxes.
And this is where, typically,
senior management will come
down from the mountain.
They'll say, I've got an idea,
execute it, my minions.
And if you think of the gears--
think of big gears
that intersect--
large gear, small gear, smaller
gear, tiny gear.
Big gear representing
senior management.
Big gear moves one quarter
turn, what
happens to small gear?
Yeah, it spins around like
a top, and finally
flies off the flywheel.
Because what's so simple to
senior management, as we all
know, who are not senior
management, not always quite
so simple making that one little
change to a program.
Typically, many, many, many
organizations are run via
conference room solution.
And I'll talk about that a
little bit more in a minute.
And then lastly, fact based
analysis, which is collecting
data, collecting reams and
reams of customer data,
processing through a thoughtful
fact-based
approach, and bringing it back
down for implementation.
And that's typically the
smallest box, in terms of how
most companies solve problems.
I think this is the enemy to a
lot of the work that we're
talking about.
Because this is the
de facto way that
people solve problems.
I live in Connecticut, so I was
on the plane ride over,
and I was reading an article in
the Times, and it was about
a new approach to solving
a crisis in the
New York area hospitals.
So three or four hospitals--
the big ones, Cornell, Columbia,
Beth Israel--
they form the consortium, and
they did some really great
customer customer research.
All made sense.
And so they talked to their
patients and said, what did
you like about your stay?
What didn't you like?
What can we do better?
How can we do a better
job of servicing you?
And one of the major issues from
the patient perspective
is I can't distinguish the
nurses from all of the other
health care workers.
Logical and make sense.
Hundreds and hundreds of people
running around, I can't
distinguish them.
So they convened a meeting
of the minds, the senior
executives, they said,
how are we going
to solve this problem?
And they came up with
a solution.
Let's immediately order all
nurses to wear white.
A little 1950s for my taste, but
nonetheless, let's order
all nurses to wear white.
And they went ahead and
procured like a
million nurse uniforms.
How well do you think that was
received on the part of the
nursing community?
Not great.
But it seems so logical.
Nurses, white, pure,
clean, sanitized,
health care, hospitals.
Why didn't the nurses like it?
Any ideas?
It wasn't their idea.
And what were their ideas?
Well, they had some
real concerns.
Number one is, white
looks great at the
beginning of the day.
But I'm dealing with bodily
fluids, ladies and gentleman.
By the end of the day, it
doesn't look white.
So it's a disaster
to maintain.
Number two, white, when washed,
tends to get sheer.
Good news for the patients,
bad news for the nurses.
And this third thing, and maybe
most importantly is they
lost their identity.
Nurses really enjoyed being
able to pick out their own
uniforms, their own scrubs.
And so they took away their
entire sense of identity.
So what seemed like such a great
idea in the board room,
when you try to implement
it, it was
an unmitigated disaster.
And that was so easily solvable
by simply inviting
the actual users of the product,
of the idea into your
ideation process.
Yet that was never considered.
The other reason I don't like
the conference room is because
it exists so far away
from the customers.
Howard Schultz--
founder and CEO, as you
know, of Starbucks--
visits 25 stores a month.
25 stores a week, excuse
me, 25 stores a week.
And when asked, why do you do
that, he said, my business is
incredibly simple--
and I would argue, actually, all
businesses are incredibly
simple, if you let them be.
My business is a simple.
What I do, simply, is I pour
coffee, I serve coffee to one
customer at a time.
That's my business.
And unless I can go out there
and taste it and smell and
watch it and observe it, I'm
going to lose track of what
really matters to my company.
So it's vital that you really
get out there and understand
what your customers are
really looking for.
What I want to do now is talk a
little bit about how you can
use some of those techniques and
get in with your customers
to maybe shake your idea tree
a little bit, and maybe give
you some new ways to promote
some creativity.
And they're a little
bit nontraditional.
So one of them is what I call
impose artificial constraints,
or ask what if?
What if you lost all of your B
to B business tomorrow, and
you had to only focus
on B to C?
How would you survive?
Conversely, what if you lost all
B to C, and you became a B
to B business exclusively?
What if you had to introduce
new product in the next six
months that would materially
add to revenue?
What if you lost half of your
employees tomorrow night?
They're all gone.
You went from a company
of 50,000
employees to 25 overnight.
What would you do?
What if you were unable to gain
a single new customer for
the next 24 months?
What would you do?
Now, you may look at me and
say, well that's absurd.
Those constraints
are ridiculous.
And I would argue, maybe, but
what it will do is it'll force
you to squeeze every last ounce
of value out of what
you're doing today.
Let me give you is
a case study.
So, working for a very large
brand name financial services
firm, and they were stunted
with how to grow.
It cost them as much to acquire
new customers as it
did for the revenue that they
couldn't get out of that
revenue box, much
as they tried.
So let's try the artificial
constraints.
And we said, in this case, what
if you weren't going to
get any new customers?
How would you survive?
And that caused them to think in
ways they'd never thought.
They've always been thinking
very vertically, they weren't
thinking laterally.
So they said, OK, well, if we
were unable to get any new
customers, how do we
maximize the value
of our current customers?
So they started thinking about
share of wallet, which wasn't
really a metric they were
thinking about in the past.
And they said, OK, we need to
maximize share of wallet.
How might we do that?
Well, the way that they were
structured was this company
sold all their products
through non-dedicated
financial advisers.
And the entire industry-- and
it's a mature industry, been
around for 50 years--
every one dedicated all of their
resources to focusing in
on a financial adviser
relationship.
Why?
Because unlike the automotive
dealers, these financial
advisers were not dedicated
to the company.
They could sell any product.
So unless we had a deep
relationship with the
financial adviser, we were
afraid we would never get any
new customers.
So all of our offices were
located by where all the
financial advisors were.
However, when we did the
artificial constraint of what
it, what they then realized--
and they did analysis they'd
never done before--
they realized that the financial
advisors typically
brought them no more than
two deals a year.
That was it.
And because they were a brand
name, they were brought to
every major deal that there was
to be had-- this is a B to
B kind of business, obviously.
So they were brought to every
possible deal because of who
they were, yet they closed their
fair share of deals.
And so, the analysis of what
if caused them to say, we
don't want to close our fair
share of deals, we want to
close our fair share of deals
as well as that of the next
three competitors.
We want it all.
And they should want it all.
Why not?
Well, in order to get it all,
the phrase we wound up using
were there always got invited to
dance, they just never took
their date home.
So the question is, how do you
increase the odds of winning
once you get taken
to the dance?
And for them, what they realized
was, they had nothing
interesting to say.
They won their fair share of
deals because they were the
same as everybody else.
What if they had something
interesting to say?
So they decided in a pilot--
and pilot is something you're
going to hear from me a lot.
I love the concept the pilots.
Rapid cycle innovation,
all about piloting.
And it's not just about
products, it's about services,
and even lines of business.
What if we pilot a
practice model?
So think consulting firms
or law firms.
And we would actually build a
practice around machinery,
health care, high tech,
utilities, what have you.
And let's go to the dance with
something really interesting
to say, not only about the
potential client, but also
about the industry trends and
how we can save them and their
participants money.
And they launched the pilot.
Within three weeks of launching
the pilot, a billion
dollar asset signed
up with them.
And they signed up with them
for one reason-- they said,
finally someone is thinking
and actually shattering
industry paradigms.
You finally have something to
say to me, as opposed to being
a commodity provider.
We're going to go ahead, and
even though we know you're in
pilot stage, we're going to
support you by transferring
all of our business.
They launched in 2012.
All pilots were fully installed
by the end of 2012,
and this client achieved their
annual revenue targets for
2013 in March of 2013.
And now other folks in the
industry, other players, are
starting to migrate to
the practice model.
And it all got there because of
the what if, the artificial
constraint.
So it's a good one, I'd
encourage you really think
about how you could maybe apply
that into some of the
challenges that you
guys are facing.
Another one like the what if is
alter your point of view.
You clearly have a point of
view, and you're more often
right than wrong.
But altering your point of view
can be a really powerful
exercise as well.
Give you another example.
Oh, and I apologize for using
financial services again, but
it's a good example.
This was an insurance company.
Fortune 100 insurance company,
been around forever, belt and
suspenders organization,
extremely conservative.
Head of insurance wanted to
introduce a new product for
the senior market, and his
challenge to us was, I want
you to create for us a
game-changing customer
experience from cradle
to grave.
From the time the customer
becomes aware of the product,
until she uses it and
gets it serviced.
I want innovation, I
want game-changing.
They've been at this
game-changing concept for this
product for about nine months
before we started
working with them.
And for them, they literally--
true story--
got as far as changing the color
of the stationary from
white to ivory in their
welcome letter.
I wouldn't exactly call
that game-changing.
It's an interesting example
to me because they only
knew what they knew.
And they didn't have the ability
to think beyond their
current paradigms.
So it's often helpful to bring
in a very different paradigm
to shake their tree.
So example here was
Mini Cooper.
Early in the year, I bought
my wife a Mini
Cooper for her birthday.
Now in the category of probably
too much information,
my wife's a former auditor at JP
Morgan, investment banker.
So she loves numbers.
I can't spend more than $10
without her knowing about it.
So clearly, trying to buy a car
without her knowing about
it probably wouldn't
pass muster.
So I went to the dealership and
I said, I want to do this
for my wife's birthday, it
needs to be a surprise.
And, quite frankly, I don't have
enough cash to pay for
this thing, so I need to go
through some sort of credit
card or write you a
check, and here's
where the problem starts.
He said, don't worry
about that.
Sit down, relax, have
a cappuccino, and
let's design your car.
I said, OK.
As you may know for Mini, there
are truly a million
different combinations of Mini
Cooper that you can design.
So we spent about three hours
having fun designing the car.
I then said, OK, there's still
the elephant in the room,
which is how do I pay
for this thing?
He said, here's what I'm
thinking-- do you have an
insurance card with you?
I said, I do.
He said, may I have it please?
I said, absolutely.
Gave him the insurance card,
made a copy, came back, said,
it's all done.
I said, what's all done?
All I gave you was an insurance
card and the specs
for the car.
He said, well, no,
it's all done.
You wife's birthday is
two weeks from now.
Here's my thinking, if this
works for you, Mr. Klapper--
I'm going to have the car driven
over and parked in your
driveway at 10:00 AM,
if that works.
It'll have a big red bow, OK?
I said, OK, it sounds good.
And it's OK with you, what I'd
like you to do is I'm going to
have the keys there.
Drive around-- it
was a Friday--
drive around for the weekend,
let your wife have some fun.
On Monday morning, have her come
in, or you come in, we'll
settle up all the finances
at that point.
I said, well, do you
need a deposit?
He said, not necessary.
Where are you going to go?
You going to steal a car?
You don't look like the
car theft kind of guy.
We'll settle the
finances later.
Enjoy the car, enjoy the
surprise, and happy birthday
to your wife.
Two weeks later, we do
that, big success.
A box comes in the mail,
beautifully gift wrapped, from
Mini, to my wife with stickers,
and coupons, and
mugs, and key chains, and all
kinds of things, Mini Cooper
membership.
And several months later, other
boxes came as well to
build the affiliation.
That's what I would call
game-changing customer service.
Why shouldn't every single
interaction be like that?
It didn't cost them
a lot more.
In fact, I would argue it cost
them no more than the crappy
experience we get when we buy
most cars, as I had three
weeks ago when I bought
my daughter a car.
Wasn't a Mini, and it was your
typical car experience, which
was, to put it kindly--
sub optimal.
We then use this approach
to insurance.
And you may say, oh, wait
a minute, insurance?
And that's what the team said.
We don't have a sexy car like
a Mini Cooper, how do
we make this work?
And we said, well, let's
talk about it.
What's the first thing that
happened on the front end?
And he said, well, you
had the choice, you
had unlimited choice.
I said, I didn't have unlimited
choice, I had the
perception of unlimited
choice.
There's a big difference.
There were a million
combinations, there we're not
a million and one.
Had I wanted a million and
one, I couldn't get it.
So all of the potential
combinations were
predetermined and costed out.
That's a pretty powerful
model.
Why can't you do that when you
offer your insurance product,
but give the customer
perception
of unlimited choice?
So that's something they
did on the front end.
So their salesforce went our
with iPads with different
options and allowed customer to
really interact with their
agent, which had never
been done before.
Next thing that arrived was a
welcome letter, hand signed by
the head of insurance, welcoming
them into this
insurance family.
Third thing that came out
was a stock certificate.
This was a security product
for senior citizens.
They could harken back to the
days of when you actually
owned stock in the company.
Highly-rated insurance company,
as part of the
product, instead of a Mini
Cooper, they got a physical
stock certificate that actually
showed tangibility to
what was heretofore an
intangible product.
Very powerful.
They instituted white glove
customer service, concierge
level service focused
on senior training.
And then the last thing was, in
the mail, about three weeks
after taking delivery of the
product, they got a blanket
with the logo the insurance
company.
A security blanket.
What did that do?
Well, it gave senior
citizens a warm
feeling about the company.
It also was a great
marketing tool.
So when one senior citizen
talked to the other--
where did you get
the new blanket?
I got it from this insurance
company when
I bought this product--
it became viral marketing.
So, taking a non-industry
example to solve a challenge
that you have is a very powerful
way to shake paradigm
and get people to
think laterally.
Last example I'll give you on
thinking differently is what I
call killing the status quo.
Newco.
Driving your company
out of business.
I've done this on the corporate
level, I've done it
on the department level,
I've even done it
on the process level.
So a company would come and say,
we want to go ahead and--
how long does your product
development
process take today?
And they'll say, 18 months.
I'll say, OK, that's more than
a little bit of time.
What would game-changing be?
And they'd say 12 months.
And said, well, think again,
that's not game-changing.
How about four weeks?
And they'll say, you don't
understand my business.
And I say, probably that's
a good thing.
Why don't we go ahead and design
a newco process without
any constraints that
you have today.
Forget structure, forget
technology, forget anything.
Let's see if we can
get a product to
market in four weeks.
Cradle to grave.
And by applying the principles
of dazzle, beguile, astound,
and delight, those are always
the founding principles of
what newco would look like.
KFC up in Canada had some
issues, more than a few.
They had 500 stores, stock price
had declined from 13 and
3/4 down to a little
more than a buck.
The brand had stopped resonating
with younger
consumers, traffic was gone.
No, they didn't go back to
Howard Johnson's, but they
were going elsewhere.
And they said to us, we need
a massive operation
transformation.
And oh, by the way, our field
turnover is 200%.
Can you help?
I said, probably.
But the last thing I would do is
tackle this as a 400 or 500
restaurant store
transformation.
That's going to fail.
Let's pick a store.
And let's pick a store and put
a charter in place that's
about dazzling, beguiling,
astounding, and
delighting our customers.
And let's build a store the way
we would want to build a
store if this were
our company.
So we formed a team--
eight people.
Half time, two constraints--
they had 45 days to get the
store turned around, and they
had a budget of $20,000.
That was it.
No other constraints.
And over the course of 45 days,
we had representation
from marketing, from product,
from R&D, from technology,
from sales, from ops, as
well as store people.
And 45 days later, we
opened a store.
300 operational improvements.
Products that we took from
the test kitchen
and launched them.
Specials that they'd
never done before.
New deals, new promotions,
door-to-door marketing, sub
zip code marketing.
Things they've never thought of
before, we put it all into
this store.
We called it model store.
And when we launched model
store, model store went from
what was in the bottom
decile--
no, not bottom, excuse me.
It was in the third or fourth
lowest decile store to the
single highest-performing store
out of 450 in the entire
organization.
Same store, sales had doubled,
average check had doubled,
profitability had doubled
against any control you'd ever
want to measure for
this model store.
And that became the blueprint
for how you roll it out across
the entire enterprise.
A very powerful concept.
Put yourself out of business,
put your process out of
business, put your department
out of business, even put your
company out of business.
It's a very powerful way
to reinvent yourself.
And you can do it in a rather
risk-free way, because if this
store didn't work?
it was one of 450.
There was no downside risk.
I'm doing it with
a company now.
They've actually completely
decimated the top two floors
of their office space, and
they're building newco to put
the entire company
out of business.
What they believe is their
business model is starting to
fade, they want to test a new
concept before they start,
they're bare bones staffing it,
lean budget, rapid time
frame-- crazy time frame--
and they're bringing over
customers one at a time, and
staffing accordingly until they
can ultimately build out
this new organization.
It's all about lateral
thinking.
Lateral thinking is extremely
difficult.
Vertical thinking is easy.
So if I were to ask you, what
was the name of your
elementary school, could
you tell me?
Yeah.
What was the name of
your first pet?
Could you tell me that?
What was the first street
that you lived?
Yeah.
You're all shaking your heads.
It's very easy to recall
historical, factual research,
because our brains are
wired that way.
They're wired in a very
vertical way.
It's when you start to make
lateral associations like the
ones we just talked about,
that's where the mental engine
seizes a little bit.
Let me put you through
an exercise
and see if this works.
Please think of a waiter.
What are the first words that
come to mind when I ask you to
think of a waiter?
Friendly.
Busy.
What else about a waiter?
What other words come to mind?
Quick word association.
Good memory.
Food?
Restaurant?
So those are the words
that you typically
associate with a waiter.
Friendly, busy, restaurant,
food, tablecloth, somebody
said candles.
Why did nobody say dump truck?
Caterpillar?
Dead cat?
Why wouldn't those be the words
that you would have
jumped to when I asked you
think of a waiter?
Why friendly, busy,
helpful, food?
Why didn't I get any votes for
dump truck or dead cat?
Because those are logical
associations, and I don't
typically associate a dead
cat with a waiter.
And I don't know where you
eat, Brian, back in
Connecticut, but out in
California, that's not the way
that things work.
True.
Typically you associate a waiter
with logical things
that you associate
with a waiter.
But a dead cat doesn't
make sense.
What I'd like to do, though, is
give you another challenge,
if you don't mind.
Pretend you're a consultant,
and you've been hired by a
failing restaurant to design
a growth strategy for that
restaurant.
And the only source of
inspiration is you must use a
dead cat in all of your ideas
and thoughts to help the
failing restaurant.
The knee jerk reaction to that
challenge, real quick.
Be honest.
Come on.
What do you think?
It's ridiculous.
Why is it ridiculous?
They're completely separate.
Yeah, and most people have the
reaction, that's ridiculous,
it's silly, it makes no sense.
And, in fact, I'm not
even going to play.
You go back to Connecticut
with your dead cat.
Very common reaction,
thank you.
But what I'm going
to ask you to do
for a second is persevere.
Go beyond the ridiculousness,
and truly now, put yourself in
that consultant's mind, and see
if you can design a growth
strategy using a dead
cat as inspiration.
Give me some thoughts.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
BRIAN KLAPPER: Love it.
So, dead cats versus live
cats on food wastage.
Perfect idea.
What else?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
BRIAN KLAPPER: OK.
BRIAN KLAPPER: Sure.
So build a restaurant that's
incredibly flexible,
incredibly agile.
Be the agile dead
cat restaurant.
When I've done this before, I've
heard things like, what
if we cater to cat lovers, and
we put some warm milk down on
the bottom of every table?
So bring your cat,
come on over.
I've heard Dead Cat Cafe.
I've heard lots of different
options for how to turn a
restaurant into a success
story using a dead cat.
But your first reaction was
the most interesting one,
which is this is silly.
The reason it's important, and
the reason I wanted to take
you through the little exercise
is because this is
what the front line feels when
they are given an idea that
they have to go ahead and
implement that they ultimately
don't think is pragmatic,
it doesn't make sense.
And we have senior management
said, here's the idea,
implement away.
Most people's reaction on the
front line is resistance.
This is ridiculous, this doesn't
make sense, this
doesn't tie to my
mental model.
But if you persevere through it,
there's often some pretty
good goodness on
the other side.
But it's not easy.
Last couple of slides.
Resistance exists at all
levels, whether it was
ridiculousness at the dead cat
story, or whether it's trying
to implement a major change
through an organization.
Most companies just want
to avoid it and
hope it goes away.
It doesn't.
It doesn't ever go away.
Best case, you'll get active
resistance, so least you know
how to help.
Worst case, it'll be passive,
where people will nod their
heads, and at the end of the
day, go back to doing what
they're doing.
The best way to overcome
resistance is to recognize
it's there and involve those
resistors into ideation and
into messaging.
So the way that I like to work,
typically, is every
project that I work on, whether
it's large or small,
always has a defined
time period--
30 days, never longer.
Even if it's a large project,
it's the piece of a project
with a measurable delivery
within 30 days.
People lose interest
after 30 days.
Management lose interest
So 30 days to deliverable.
I love to have a pilot working
within 30 days.
Team composition?
Love it to be no more than five
to seven people, flat
out, working hard.
Think of the analogy of a crew
in scull, when you get to more
than five, six, eight people,
you have people that are
coasting, not people
that are working.
So I like the team size capped
to five to seven, people 30
day deliverable, quantitative
mandate.
And make sure the people who are
ideating are the ones that
are ultimately going to be
response for implementing.
So make sure the idea comes from
senior management so they
buy into it, they resource the
project properly, and,
ultimately, it's the doers,
the ideators, that are
responsible for implementation.
And what you're going to find is
you are absolutely going to
turn resistance into passion,
because people love to
implement the work that they
had a hand in creating.
Final thoughts are I know
these talks happen with
tremendous frequency here, and
hopefully at some of the
better ones, you're able
to walk away with
an idea or two that--
maybe there was a phrase that
said, well, that was kind of
interesting.
I learned a little something.
It was worth giving up my
lunch hour to listen to.
But what I hope is that you
could take something away from
this, even if it's just one
concept, and try and implement
it into your day to day job.
So, depending on where you
are in the organization--
whether it is senior management
and it's about
building a committed team and
living the change you want.
Whether you're lower in the
organization, and you want to
hold leaders accountable.
Whether it's about creating
organizational energy.
There's clearly tons of energy
here in this building, but
around a specific project.
Adopt a personal approach.
Own the change.
I hope that some of the lessons
will serve you as you
go out and continue
your careers.
So, I wish you the best, and
I thank you very much.